I think with ADHD the problem is that
you sort of I'm gonna try to rephrase
this because I'm I'm sort of going on a
tangent what just happened was I saying
I misbehaved a lot as a kid but I didn't
mean to you the natural environment of a
classroom is very non conducive to
somebody with ADHD you know just like
this quiet room you're sitting at this
table a bunch of other kids are all
doing their work it was almost like like
it's sensory overload like everything is
coming at you all at once I would be
trying to focus on this teacher and then
all of a sudden I would like snap to it
again and I have missed half of what the
teacher talked about it was like you're
high or something like a good sign it's
kind of someone died
well the side effects of ADHD is a sort
of an inability or are at least tough
time staying still concentrating
focusing on day to day tasks I feel like
my thoughts are sort of on like a
carousel in my brain and it's going in
circles and each thought stopped for
like two seconds in front of my eyes I
can barely grasp it and then it's gone
third day I was at BuzzFeed I was taking
some like safety tests with my friend
fellow producer here Caitlin and I'm
like already lost on like the packet I
look over and like Caitlin's answer that
the first ten questions already and it's
just that that's the story of my life is
like looking over to my friend and being
like what did you just do that
I have been on some form of medication
ever since I was 13 I stopped taking
medication for me because I just didn't
like the way it made me feel they curved
my appetite I was losing weight but the
medication provides me with clarity when
I'm not on my medicine it feels like the
smallest tasks are really overwhelming
because I can't visualize and focus on
the simple process I have to plan things
out I have to write everything down or
else I forget I don't advocate that
everyone go off their meds they don't
need to it's for me that was something
that I felt I wanted to do it looks
different in everybody I would just wish
people were a little more sensitive with
like the verbal assumptions they make I
just wish people believed it was real my
ADHD is like the realest thing in my
life like I can't reach out and touch it
but I can feel it
you